ζήτηση ανααγωίζητον και νέα αναβολη αλλά είναι δύσκολο γιατί ο στόχος δεν αλλάζει ωσπου αλλάζει
στα χρόνο διαγράμματα ενώ ότελικό στόχος παραμένι ο ίδιος απλά ς πρόχλη στο πρόπλημα για
πιο μετά και δυστιχός αυτή είναι ονοτροπία απου μας διακατέχει ιαδώ και δεκαϊτείες γιατί αυτές
οι αποφάσεις έχουν πια πολιτικό κόστος από την άλλι γνωρίζουμε ότι κος ίκος ι έξέχουμε
εκλογές και δστυχώς οι εκλογε στην κύπρο δεν είναι καλό πράγμα για τον μέσω πολίτη
γιατί παίνουμε σε μια κατάσταση πραγμάτων όπου απλά στη βουλή τα πάντα ενερυστά δεν σκέφτονται
με την απολι δηλογική αλλά σκεφτονται με με άλλους με πότερο στόχο την εκλογή ή
την επιβίωση θα ελεγα άρα όλα αυτά η συγκυρία δεν είναι καλή για τον κύπριο
πολίτια δεν πρέπει να κάνουμε τα βάντα μαύρα να μη λά είμα ότι είναι μια
κατάσταση πραγματων εκτός ελέγχου αλλά είναι μια δύσκολι καδάσταση πραγμαδο και νέο η πραγματική οικονομία
υποφέρει δηλαδή ο μέσως πολίτης αλλά και η μέση επιχείρηση γιατί και η μικρομεσίες επιχειρήσεις
που είναι ρα έχω κοκαλιά της κυπριακής οικονομίας αντιμετωπίζουντ είτα προβλήματα ήτηρας του να πό
αυτή την πράση η φορολόγια εβεβαίως όταν κάποιος έχει να στόλο αυτοκινήτων όταν το πειτρέλειο
είναι το βασικό καύσημο τα ορικτά δηλαδή να βασικό καύσημο στην κύπρο αυτή στιγμή και
το ο κόστος ενέργειας συνεχώς αυξάνεται ι δουλάχιστον δεμειώνεται όλοι λέμε ότι χωρίς φυσικό αέριο
δεν μπορεί να γίνει η μείωση του ηλεκτρικού κόστους που είναι δελάστιο κόστος για όλος
και για τους πολίτες και για τις επιχειρής για τους πολίτες υπάρχει αυτό το προσωγαλινό
μέτρο βλάχι στο για ένα χρόνομίωσης του φύπια που είναι έθα έλεγα να παυσύπονο για
να πάμε πιο κάτω αλλά δεν είναι και η λίσεη το προβλήματος αυτό το γαμπανάκι
τον προηγούμενο κστετροόρον από το δούνο του πρέπει να μας προβληματήσει εμέσω γι να πληθορίσμου
ή ήταν μία προεϊδοποίησει ωστε να ειρεμίσουμε λίγο και με κάποιες ζαβάνες και με διάφορα
αλλάτο δούνο του και γενικά ι θεσμή κτυπούν καμπά